bonjour
aujourd'hui on va les de l'identité
la question
fait partie de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les sujets clivants
c'est un sujet qui divise
parce qu'il ya plusieurs manières de
concevoir l'identité
il ya plusieurs manières de la définir
et selon la manière dont on va la
définir
arrivé du tout aux mêmes conclusions
constatées dans certains débats
d'actualité
par exemple dans les débats sur
l'identité nationale
ou sur l'identité de genre
et très souvent on a affaire à des
débats houleux parce que les critères à
partir desquels on va envisager
l'identité ne seront pas du tout les
mêmes
il faut croire que si tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord sur ce qu'est
l'identité
sur les critères à partir desquels on
définit l'identité
tout le monde en revanche à un point de
vue sur la question
et une grande partie des désaccords
s'évanouirait
si on prenait tout simplement la peine
de définir ces critères
prenons le carnet de l'identité
nationale
pour les uns l'identité nationale c'est
l'origine
on est français on est chinois on est
amérindiens
parce que nos ancêtres l'était et que
l'identité se transmet par ce qu'on
appelle la filiation
ou l'hérédité
dans cette conception
l'identité
chose de fixe
elle se définit par la permanence
par la permanence dans le temps
et c'est d'ailleurs une idée qu'on
retrouve dans la quête des origines
la quête des origines c'est la quête du
point initial
c'est la quête de l'instant zéro
qui donne du sens à ce que nous sommes
autrement dit qui nous confère notre
identité
on voit bien
à de nombreux enfants nés sous x
desbiens cette expression
être né sous x
être né sous l'inconnu
être l'enfant de l'inconnu
l'enfant de l'inconnu
parce que nous sommes des êtres
historique
ce que nous ne sommes sur terre que
parce que des milliers de générations se
sont succédé à travers le temps pour
faire de nous ce que nous sommes
l'enfant née sous x
c'est l'enfant qui part avec l'ignorance
de 50 % de ce qu'il est
c'est un peu brutal dit comme ça mais il
faut parler avec les personnes
concernées pour se rendre compte que
c'est très souvent comme ça que j'ai
vécu
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse on
comprendra beaucoup mieux pourquoi les
hommes ont historiquement chercher à
contrôler le ventre des femmes
on comprend que l'identité du père
et celle dont il est possible de douter
le père
et pas toujours sûr d'être le père
l'identité de la mère est en plus
difficiles à méconnaître
pour l'instant je ferme la parenthèse
donc ici on vient de ouah ce qu'on
pourrait appeler m la conception fixiste
de l'identité
le fait que l'identité serait quelque
chose de figé dans le temps et qui
impliquerait l'idée de transmission
et cette conception fixiste va de pair
avec la conception in et east de
l'identité
alors j'explique
l'inegi sme c'est le fait de considérer
que certains de nos attributs serait ine
autrement dit
serait présent en nous dès la naissance
dans cette conception l'identité c'est
quelque chose qu'on porte
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on choisit
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on
construit
c'est quelque chose qu'on reçoit
qu'on transmet
et
nous en rendre compte
une idée qu'on partage assez largement
quand on dit par exemple je suis comme
ça
c'est ma nature
c'est ma nature sous-entendu je ne peux
rien y faire
je suis fait comme ça
sartre rappelé à la mauvaise foi c'est à
dire la tendance à s'auto essentialiser
dire je suis comme ça c'est dire qu'il
est inutile de vouloir essayer de
changer
parce que l'identité ne se modifie pas
dire c'est ma nature c'est sous-entendre
qu'il existe quelque chose en nous qui
déterminent ce que nous sommes au delà
de notre volonté
ça la conception in et east de
l'identité
fait que l'identité serait une empreinte
posé sur nous dès le moment notre
naissance
alors précisons d'emblée que sur le plan
biologique
c'est effectivement le cas
tite et génétique
notre héritage génétique comme son nom
l'indiqué on le reçoit et on fait avec
on ne peut pas je
là où la question va se poser c'est sur
l'identité culturelle et sur l'identité
psychologique
c'est à dire sur la dimension
immatérielle de l'identité
votre taille la couleur de vos yeux ou
de vos cheveux ça fait partie de votre
identité biologique
en revanche votre identité psychique ce
qu'on appelle la personnalité
fait que vous êtes ce que vous êtes
indépendamment de votre patrimoine
génétique
c'est une autre affaire
là que les désaccords apparaîtront entre
ceux qui verront la personnalité comme
le résultat de nos caractéristiques
biologiques
comme l'extension de nos
caractéristiques biologiques
et ceux qui y verront une pure
construction
action indépendante de nos attributs ine
donc d'un côté une conception in et east
de l'identité et de l'autre une
conception
constructiviste de l'identité
constructiviste au sens de socialement
construits
l'identité serait
produits de nos interactions avec le
monde
c'est une idée qui est très présente
dans les sciences sociales
contemporaines dans lesquels on envisage
d'être humains comme le produit de son
environnement
certains appelleront ça du
réductionnisme le fait d'enlever à
l'être humain sa singularité
fait de le considérer comme une chose
parmi les choses c'est à dire de
l'envisager comme un être inanimé
je prends le mot inanimée dans son sens
étymologique c'est à dire dépourvu d'âme
jusqu'au xviiie siècle on admettait
l'existence d'une âme humaine
d'ailleurs âmes se disait suquet aux
grecs
qui a donné six schisme
et donc l'identité l'identité subjective
l'identité personnelle c'est l identité
de larmes
carte définissait l'identité humaine par
la pensée
parce que la pensée c'est une propriété
de l'âme
elham s'esquisse un prix mais sur
l'individu au moment de la conception
c'est l'âme qui conférait à l'homme son
essence on
mais le problème de cette conception
d'identité ou en tout cas ce qui a posé
problème à un certain moment de
l'histoire européenne
c'est que le concept dame est un concept
religieux
or au xviiie siècle le siècle des
lumières
la légitimité de la religion a commencé
à être contestées
contesté au profit de la raison de la
science
surtout de l'expérimentation
à partir du xviiie siècle on a commencé
à étudier l'être humain comme un être
naturel parmi les autres
et donc à lui ôter ce privilège divin
qui en faisait un être doué d'une âme
est donc un être au dessus du règne
naturel
devenu un mécanisme
un mécanisme interagissant avec d'autres
mécanismes comme des particules de
matière interagissent entre elles pour
former des particules plus complexe
à partir de ce moment là qu'on a cessé
de rattacher l'identité à l'âme pour lui
préférer
l'expérience
l'identité c'était le produit de
l'expérience de l'individu
la notion d'âme fut jugée obsolète elle
fut jugée dépassée
surtout elle n'était réalité observable
or au xviiie siècle
l'oeil tout ce qui n'est pas observable
la science la connaissance rigoureuse du
monde et de l'homme ça devait être un
projet reposant sur l'observation
pas sur des croyances
sur des spéculations
or de plus en plus de scientifiques et
de philosophes de cette époque comme par
exemple la mettrie
les lames comme une pure spéculation
et une non en réalité
parce que son nez distance ne reposer
que sur la croyance en son existence
il faut bien comprendre ce contexte ce
compte intellectuel qui fait qu'un
concept qui a pu traverser l'histoire
comme le concept dame
c'est retrouver progressivement
discréditer
l'europe du xviiie siècle est dominé par
l'empirisme
elle est dominée par une vision de la
science reposant sur l'observation des
faits
donc il était inévitable que tôt ou tard
le concept dame fassent les frais de
cette évolution des mentalités
et c'est là qu'on arrive à david yom
vidyo mme philosophe écossais né en 1711
donc un contemporain de la mettrie
la vie des hommes qui avaient une vision
diamétralement opposée à celle de
descartes
puisque des cartes était un partisan de
l'inegi sme il pensait que les facultés
humaines était innée
tandis que youm était un partisan de
l'empirisme c'est à dire qu'il pensait
que les facultés humaines était acquise
acquis c'est à dire quel était le
produit de l'expérience
et donc pour yum ce n'était plus l'âme
qui définissait l'identité d'une
personne
c'était son expérience
c'était son vécu
alors pour comprendre cette conception
de l'identité qui était celle de yum il
va falloir revenir sur ce qu'on appelle
l'empirisme
l'empirisme du latin emperia
c'est la théorie qui affirme que toutes
nos idées dérive de notre expérience
je répète que toutes nos idées dérive de
notre expérience
ou alors évident son s'arrêter juste à
cette phrase on risquerait de faire
fausse route
un bien parce que le mot expérience n'a
pas la même signification en philosophie
que dans les usages courants
dans l' usage courant l'expérience c'est
la pratique dans un domaine
par exemple qu'on a de l'expérience dans
le domaine du commerce ou dans le
domaine associatif que sais-je
à de notre expérience professionnelle
on parlera de nos expériences de voyage
de nos expériences amoureuse ou sexuelle
tout ça
enfin il y a un lien
dans le sens où chez les empiristes
l'expérience
c'est tout ce qui a à voir avec nos
perceptions
mondy avec nous
sion
c'est ça le meilleur synonyme de
l'expérience au sens philosophique du
terme
donc la paire on s'est aussi bien la
vision l'audition la palpation bref tout
ce qui passe par nos sens
donc quand on ra d'expérience ici il
faudra entendre l'ensemble de nos
sensations
actuellement vous êtes en train de
m'écouter
donc vous faites l'expérience par louis
voir
vous regarder par la fenêtre vous voyez
un avion qui passe dans le ciel
vous faites l'expérience par la vue de
l'avion
c'est ça l'expérience
donc voyez que ce n'est pas la même
chose que d'avoir de l'expérience même
si rigoureusement parlant vos
expériences sont bien une collection
d'expériences
vos expériences professionnelles
amoureuse ou sexuelle
sont bien un composé d'expériences
sensorielles
la différence étant que dans
l'expérience au sens courant
on inclut davantage on englobe davantage
que nos simples sensations
inclus nos émotions on inclut nos
pensées
bref l'expérience au sens courant
large que la perception
oui mais ce que dit yum
te manque en réalité
tout ce qu'on inclut dans l'expérience
provient de la perception
car tous convient absolument tous on vit
n'est rien d'autre que le résultat de
nos perceptions
alors cet impôt
loupé dans l'épisode d'aujourd'hui
parce que j'en ai déjà parlé dans un
précédent épisode sur youm que je vous
invite à écouter si vous n'avez pas
encore fait
revient plus en détail sur la manière
dont pour yum
les idées se constitue à partir de
l'expérience
c'est ce qu'on appelle la théorie des
connexions
connexion font que la sensation du show
et la sensation du froid
vont faire naître dans notre esprit le
concept de chaux et le concept de froid
et que c'est par la répétition de nos
expériences
des connexions s'établissent entre les
faisant ainsi naître en nous
les idées
donc je reprend là où je m'étais arrêté
que pour you
absolument tout ce qu'on vit n'est rien
d'autre que le résultat de nos
perceptions
pour comprendre cette idée je vais vous
proposer une petite expérience c'est le
cas de le dire
petite expérience de pensée
je vais vous demander de revivre par la
pensée tout ce que vous avez fait depuis
que vous êtes levé ce matin
je vais vous des deux vous repassez
mentalement le film de votre journée tel
que vous l'avez vécu
et j'insiste sur le tel que vous l'avez
vécu
votre réveil sonne
vous vous levez
vous vous faites un café
vous regardez vos messages sur votre
téléphone bref
un début de journée comme les autres
ma question est la suivante
que voyez vous
est-ce que vous voyez vous même en train
de vous lever
mondy est ce que la caméra qui filme
votre journée est à l'extérieur de vous
non
la caméra qui filme votre journée elle
est dans vos yeux
la caméra qui filme votre journée
c'est vous
et pourquoi c'est important
parce que ça veut dire que dans les
faits
votre vie
rien d'autre que ce que vous percevez
quand vous temps
vous voyez pas en train de vous lever
vous voyez ce qu'il ya sous vos yeux
vous voyez votre oreiller votre
couverture
vous voyez votre main qui attrape le
téléphone pour arrêter le réveil
bref vous êtes en vue subjective
en fps comme on dit dans les jeux vidéo
c'est à dire que votre vécu sensorielle
se fait toujours à la première personne
c'est artificiellement qu'on s'imagine
en train de faire quelque chose
comme si on était le témoin extérieur de
ce qu'on faisait
en réalité tout ce qu'on vit
on le vit à travers ses propres yeux
quand appelé ça le mois 30 dental
le mois transcendantale par opposition
au mois empirique
le mois transcendantale c'est quand on
voit le monde depuis son point de vue
subjectif
le mois empirique c'est quand on se
représente soi même en train de voir le
monde
vous êtes en voiture
vous allez au travail
qu'est ce que vous voyez
est ce que vous voyez vous même en train
de conduire
non
vous voyez
vous voyez vos mains sur le volant
et tout ce que vous vivez tout ce que
vous vivez réellement
vous le vivez à travers l'écran de votre
point de vue
maintenant allons un peu plus loin
si tout ce que vous vivez vous le vivez
à vers votre point de vue ça veut dire
que votre expérience
rien d'autre que la juxtaposition de
toutes vos perceptions
alors le mot juxtaposition est un peu
ambigu parce qu'il donne l'impression
que nos perceptions sont hachées
il donne l'impression qu'une perception
succède à une autre comme les 24 images
par seconde au cinéma
oui mais justement
ce que nous dit yum c'est que c'est
comme ça que fonctionnent nos
perceptions
chaque perception succède à l'autre et
c'est par l'imagination que nous
reconstruisons une impression de
continuité entre nos perceptions
je vais essayer d'être clair là dessus
parce que c'est vraiment fondamental
quand vous êtes vous voiture à chaque
seconde vous voyez quelque chose de
différent
même quand vous êtes au feu rouge et que
toutes les voitures sont immobilisées
il y a toujours quelque chose de nouveau
en train d'apparaître
le film votre vie ne se met jamais en
pause
l'image de ij jamais
vous êtes à l'arrêt mais il y a des
pieds traverse
il y à une moto qui passe entre les
voitures
il y à l'automobiliste dans le
rétroviseur en train de se curer le nez
où est ce que je veux en venir
au fait que chaque 2 est l'occasion
d'une perception nouvelle
et que le film de votre existence
c'est le défilé ininterrompu
de perception qui s'enchaînent les unes
les autres
et comme jeu
nos perceptions ce n'est pas seulement
ce que nous voyons
ce sont aussi les sons
et klaxons le bruit du moteur
ce sont odeurs
le diffuseur de parfum
bon
chaque saut monde est un concentré de
sensations nouvelles
nouvelle parce qu'à chaque instant le
monde se modifie
le
on se modifie
et donc si l'environnement se modifie à
chaque instant la perception de cet
environnement se modifie également
à chaque seconde qui passe
ce n'est plus le même monde que vous
avez sous les yeux
mais on est bien d'accord que vous en
tant qu individu ayant affaire au monde
vous n'avez pas l'impression que vos
perceptions se renouvelle à chaque
seconde
pourquoi
parce que votre imagination
produits l'illusion de la continuité
votre imagination réuni vos sensations
elle réunit vos perceptions
pour vous donner une impression de
fluidité et de cohésion entre les
perceptions
et donc vous n'avez pas l'impression de
vivre une succession d'états
vous avez l'impression de vivre un état
stable
se modifie superficiellement
je prendrai l'exemple
si vous êtes assis dans un parc
et que vous regardez des canards qui
nagent sur un lac
vous allez avoir une impression de
fluidité
l'impression que chaque seconde qui
s'écoule
rien d'autre que le prolongement de la
précédente
donc vous dire que chaque seconde est un
renouvellement perception
par contre si tout à coup
vous voyez un éclair dans le ciel
vous allez vous dire tiens une
perception nouvelle
mais en réalité
les clercs qui surgit dans le ciel de
façon soudaine
ne constitue pas une perception plus
nouvelle que les 5 cm parcouru par le
canard sur le lac
la différence entre ces deux perceptions
ce n'est pas que l'une des deux est
nouvelle
les deux sont entièrement nouvelle
la différence c'est que l'une des deux
était inattendue
l'éclair dans le ciel tout vous y
attendiez pas
alors que la position du canard sur le
lac vous pouviez l'anticiper
vous l'avais anticipé
et bien cette hantise bon c'est ça qui
crée une impression de fluidité
c'est ça qui crée une impression de
continuité entre les perceptions
quand on écoute une chanson
à chaque fois qu'il y à une nouvelle
note on a en tête les notes précédentes
et si on connaît la chanson
on a aussi en tête les notes suivantes
donc
impression continuité
la noce de mélodies n'aurait aucun sens
sans cette impression de continuité
tandis que si vous êtes chez vous
c'est la nuit
e le silence règne
si tout à vous vous en rendez une
explosion
une impression de rupture
la rupture
ce
et pourtant dans les faits entre la note
de musique et l'explosion
n'y a pas plus de rupture dans l'une que
dans l'autre
dans les deux cas il y as rupture parce
que dans les deux cas il y a
renouvellement sensorielle
chaque instant est un renouvellement
sensorielle
la différence étant dans un cas
on remarque le renouvellement
sensorielle
parce qu'on ne s'y attend pas
l'explosion
tandis que dans l'autre cas la musique
si à temps
et parce qu'on s'y attend
remarque pas qu'il y a renouvellement
sensorielle
qu'est ce qui fait que la nouveauté
créée en nous un sentiment d'intensité
là où l'habitude créée au contraire un
effet de platitudes
c'est justement le fait que dans
l'habitude
le renouvellement sensorielle n'ai pas
remarqué
je prenais tout à l'heure l'exemple de
la voiture
en voiture on est plus attentif sur un
trajet qu'on ne connaît pas
que sur un trajet familier
ateras gfr m
est un trajet auquel on s'attend
donc on diminue sa vigilance
en diminution parce qu'on se dit ce sera
comme d'habitude
il n'y aura rien de nouveau
grave erreur
il y a toujours du nouveau
c'est quand on parle cip qu'il n'y aura
rien de nouveau
à venir ce qui est nouveau
donc
2 l'habitude fondée sur la mémoire qui
produit un sentiment de continuité entre
les choses
c'est parce qu'on ne remarque pas que
nos perceptions se renouvelle à chaque
instant
c'est parce qu'on ne remarque pas que
littéralement chacune de nos perceptions
et unique absolument unique et
singulière qu'on a cette impression de
constance et de stabilité entre les
événements
quand on démarre sa journée on ne se dit
pas que notre réveil est unique
que notre café est unique
ou que notre journée est unique
on se dit c'est la routine
on se dit une journée de
une journée
du pas de rhume fondamentale entre hier
et aujourd'hui
de même qu'il n'y aura pas de rupture
fondamentale entre aujourd'hui et demain
l'habitude c'est ce qui nous ouah de la
continuité et de la stabilité
dans le renouvellement permanent des
choses
depuis tout on peut arc je n'ai toujours
pas commencé à répondre à la question de
l'identité chez yum
en fait
c'est le contraire
est en plein dedans
j'irai même que jusqu'à dire
y est on y a déjà répondu
c'est juste que j'ai emprunté un chemin
inattendu
pour ne et on vous
platitude 2
qu'est ce que l'identité
l'identité
c'est le sentiment du mois
c'est le sentiment que le mois
d'aujourd'hui est dans la continuité du
mois d'hier
lexical l'identité c'est ce qui fait
qu'une chose ou une personne est
identique
identique à quoi
à elle même
le mot vient 1 idem qui veut dire le
même
no trident et c'est ce qui fait que nous
sommes nous mêmes
c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes le
même
de là les modifications qui a fait notre
corps et notre esprit
bien du vous n'êtes pas exactement le
même aujourd'hui que lorsque vous étiez
enfant
vous n'êtes pas exactement le même qu il
y a dix vingt ou trente ans
mais vous êtes le même
sens où tout ce que vous avez vécu dans
votre vie
c'est vous qui l'avez vécu
vous savez ce qu'on dit on ne change pas
on évolue
autrement dit on reste la même personne
le mois c'est ce qui perdure le temps au
delà de toutes les micro variations
qu'il subit
une ride qui apparaît
quelques kilos en plus
1 ouf le mans plus prononcée quand vous
montez les escaliers
tout ça ça ne terre pas votre identité
sanaa le ter pas votre moi profond
votre moi profond ce qui fait que vous
êtes qui vous êtes et pas quelqu'un
d'autre
à de quelques variations physique
la preuve c'est que vous pouvez vous
teindre les cheveux
vous pouvez même faire de la chirurgie
esthétique
vous n'en devient et pas pour autant
quelqu'un d'autre
vous deviendrez le même
caractéristiques différentes
autrement dit
identité sous l'angle de la permanence
notre moi c'est
east en arrière-plan de nos
modifications
nous avons
sion
substantialiste de l'identité
la substance c'est ce qui se tient
derrière les apparences
toujours de manière métaphorique que
nous disons que nous ne sommes plus la
même personne
vous savez quand on dit depuis qu'il me
tarde et ça je ne suis plus la même
personne
et enfin bien sûr si vous êtes la même
vous êtes là personne
modification
c'est ça la conception substantialiste
de l'identité
or
ce que nous dit yum
c'est que cette conception de l'identité
une illusion
ce que nous disons
c'est que le moi est une fiction
l'identité est une fiction
et c'est une produite par le iman d'une
unité entre nos expériences
le mois c'est l'agent d'unification de
nos perceptions
c'est le dénominateur commun de toutes
et bien pour yum si le mois n'est rien
d'autre que le dénominateur commun de
nos perceptions
ça veut dire que le moi est une illusion
pour yu mme lemoine a pas de réalité
ce qui a une réalité c'est l'ensemble
des expériences et des perceptions que
nous rapportons à une entité abstraite
que nous appelons le mois
mais le mois n'a pas d'existence en
dehors des expériences qu'il a vécues
le mois n'a pas d'existence
sinon comme garant de l'unité de mes
expériences
et c'est parce que nous avons une
mémoire
10 c'est parce que nous avons le
souvenir de nos expériences passées que
nous pouvons rapporter l'ensemble de ses
expériences à une entité qui serait le
mois
en d'autres termes pour yom
nous ne sommes rien d'autre
une collection de perception
le mois s'est tu
sion d'état sensorielle
la thèse de yum est un peu d certains tu
parce que comme je le disais à l'instant
la plupart d'entre nous avons une
conception substantialiste de l'identité
agim que nous sommes quelque chose de
plus que ce que nous avons vécu
or pour yom ces salles illusion
rappelons que hugh mettait un empiriste
et que pour les empiristes
présupposés qu'il existe autre chose que
ce dont nous pouvons faire l'expérience
présupposés qu'il existe une âme ou un
mois qui résistera aux défilés de nos
perceptions
c'est déjà de la spéculation
pour yom à chaque fois que chon à nous
définir
à chaque fois que nous faisons nous
mêmes une entité séparée de notre
expérience concrète et actuelle nous
spéculons
nous nous inventons un mois comme
d'autres s'invente une âme pour se
donner une consistance
ça n'a rien de concret
la seule
soit concrètes et concrètement
connaissable
c'est notre expérience
dont 4 bon vous n'êtes pas un tel
en train de m'écouter
vous êtes
l'écoutent elle même
l'oreille qui entendent voix
et vos pensées c'est à dire le contenu
de votre conscience
ce ne sont pas les pensées d'untel ou
d'untel
ce sont les pensées issus de la voie que
vous entendez
et c'est tout
ça s'arrête là
sortie de la perception
il n'y a plus rien
il n'y a pas d'identité au delà de nos
perceptions
imaginez vous calfeutré dans pièce sans
lumière
tout est noir
est ce que vous êtes toujours
chose
oui
vous êtes vos autres selon
vous est ce que vous en dès
le bruit à l'extérieur
ce
à voir priver du sens de la vue on vous
prive du sens de l'ouïe
qu'est ce qu'il vous reste
il vous reste encore trois sens
le toucher l'odorat le goût
bien supposons
prive
ces trois derniers sens
imaginez que tous vos canaux sensorielle
soit coupée
voilà
anesthésiés
est ce que vous êtes encore chose
sommes nous
11 dès lors que nous sommes amputé de
tous nos moyens de perception
on peut répondre oui
on peut ré londres qui nous reste notre
esprit
il nous reste notre conscience
et c'est là que la réponse de yum met un
terme à toute discussion
parce que de quoi se votre esprit
de quoi se compose votre conscience
elles se comptent nous devons sauver ire
des souvenirs issu de vos pairs option
elle ce conte aux deux pensées
dépenses est issu de vaud sion
pour yum tout ce qu'il se passe
provient de nos perceptions
nos idées sont les résidus manteau de
nos perceptions
et donc d il n'y a plus de perception
il n'y a plus de conscience
parce qu il plus de contenu de
conscience
et s'il n'y a plus de contenu de
il n'ya plus d'identité
il n'y a plus rien
imaginez qu'après
voir privé de vos cinq sens
on vous ôte toute mémoire
tout souvenir
voile annonce
anesthésiés mais à mener
vous ne savez plus qui vous êtes
et vous ne pouvez plus rien naître
le moins une non parce que quand la
perception disparaît
à disparaît
je cite
il est des fileuses
in que nous sommes à chaque instant
intimement conscient de ce que nous
appelons notre moi que nous en sentons
l'existence et la continuité d'existence
pour moi quand je pénètre le plus
intimement dans ce que j'appelle moi
même je tombe toujours sur une
perception particulière ou sur une autre
de chaleur ou de froid de lumière ou
dhombres d'amour ou de haine de douleur
ou de plaisir je ne parvient jamais à
aucun moment à me saisir moi même sans
une perception et je ne peux jamais rien
observé d'autre que la perception toute
idée réelle doit provenir d'une
impression particulière mais le mois où
la personne ce n'est pas une impression
particulière mais ce à quoi nos diverses
idées et impressions sont censés se
rapporter si une impression donne
naissance à l'idée du moins cette
impression doit nécessairement demeurée
la même invariablement pendant toute la
durée de notre vie puisque c'est ainsi
que le mois est supposé existé mais il
n'y a pas d' un pression constante et
invariable la douleur et le plaisir le
chagrin et la joie les passions et les
sensations se succèdent et n'existe
jamais tout en même temps ce ne peut
donc pas être d'une de ses impressions
ni de tout autre que provient l'idée du
mois et en conséquence
il n'y a pas une telle idée
il peut sembler difficile
m que non identité ne soit rien d'autre
que la collection de nos perceptions et
de nos expériences passées
parce qu'une telle conception nous
dégrade
elle nous
rétrograde
mais si on rend vain la perspective
est qu'on admet que oui
nous ne sommes bel et bien une
collection d'expériences
alors ça signifie que
tout ce que nous avons vécu
et non seulement
mais précieux
infiniment mieux
car ça veut dire que personne d'autre
que vous
q ce que vous avez vécu
et que les souffles ir de ce que vous
avez vécu
reposant vous
nous portons où l'empreinte de ce que
vécu
nous portons en nous l'empruntent
l'empreinte de nos émotions
de nos défauts nos réussites
de noël et de nos amours
et chaque ray comme une petite avant sur
cloué au tableau de notre collection
alors que votre fait d' aventure
et que votre collection
soit la plus belle des collections
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]